schnelleres tempo schon nächste woche
will die scheidende cdu chefin mit ihren
möglichen nachfolgern verhandeln
retouren für die tonne zurück geschickte
ware wird millionenfach weggeworfen das
will die regierung ändern und keine
revolution in der katholischen kirche
der papst hält fest am zölibat und
verwehrt frauen weiterhin wichtige ämter
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg und und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem mittwoch
norbert könig ist auch dabei für den
spanier schön genommen ein parteitag im
dezember soll den kanzlerkandidaten der
cdu führen
doch dieser zeitplan der noch
amtierenden parteichefin gerät mehr und
mehr ins rutschen
schon nächste woche will annegret kramp
karrenbauer zu einer art speeddating mit
möglichen nachfolge kandidaten einladen
zwei bekennen sich schon zu ihren
ambitionen gesundheitsminister jens
spahn und friedrich merz
es gibt bewegung in der kulisse aus
berlin will ich eigentlich wollte ich
ein spanner mittag hier als
gesundheitsminister ausschließlich etwas
zum corona virus sagen aber dann sagte
er beiläufig auch noch etwas über seinen
ehrgeiz und seiner absichten
ich habe immer gesagt das habe ich denke
ich auch dokumentiert in den letzten
eineinhalb zwei jahren dass ich bereit
bin verantwortung zu übernehmen in
welcher konstellation das aber geschieht
darüber reden wir jetzt eben in den
nächsten tagen und ich finde wir müssen
uns doch alle mal schaffen sowohl wir
wie sie das erst mal alles vielleicht
ein paar tage dauern darf
damit man einfach in ruhe die dinge
besprechen kann
damit bringt hier einsparen sich als
erster in position und andere unter
zugzwang sich auch bald zu erklären
wenige stunden später heißt es auch aus
dem umfeld von friedrich merz er sei zur
kandidatur bereit
gestern abend hatte er bei diesem
auftritt in magdeburg seine ambitionen
zumindest nicht dementiert ich möchte
dass wir das in einer anständigen form
untereinander austragen und ich werde
dazu beitragen dass diese anständige
form gewahrt wird bei aller
unterschiedlichkeit die wir vielleicht
auch in den personen und in den handel
akteuren haben die parteichefin will mit
spar- und märz und allen die
möglicherweise auch noch interesse
zeigen schon ab nächster woche
einzelgespräche führen von der csu war
sie gestern zu einem schnellen zeitplan
aufgefordert worden
ich bin mir ganz sicher dass markus
söder als bayerischer ministerpräsident
auch an der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz teilnehmen wird das
werde ich auch tun
warnende worte kommen von wolfgang
schäuble nichts überstürzen erst inhalte
klären dann die personalfragen mal sehen
ob in die partei am ende hört ein
kernproblem der cdu die frage der
abgrenzung nach links und rechts es gilt
der parteitagsbeschluss keine
zusammenarbeit mit afd und auch nicht
mit der linken
der fall zeigt aber dass dadurch gerade
in ostdeutschland die spielräume für die
cdu sehr eng werden
zu eng sagen viele christdemokraten an
der basis andreas weise hat sich in
thüringen umgehört
heiligenstadt im eichsfeld nordwest
thüringen berühmt für seine heilquellen
doch auch hier haben sie noch kein
mittel gefunden um die leiden einer arg
gerupften und zerstrittenen thüringer
cdu zu kurieren
ich glaube schon dass sich viele in
einer zwangsjacke fühlen und sie
eigentlich auch ein stückchen angst
haben und traurig sind dass sie eben
selbst dieses land in zu einer ecke
hineinmanövriert haben und auch heute
keine lösung in sicht der politische
betrieb in erfurt er ruht winterferien
und hilfe von der bundes cdu ist nicht
in sicht beim
unvereinbarkeitsbestimmungen linke
bleibt das adenauer haus hat wir wählen
ja nicht den könig von thüringen sondern
ministerpräsident und herr ramelow ist
der kandidat der linkspartei und in
dieser linkspartei landtagsfraktion sind
wiederum problematische leute die
problematische politische position haben
und das kann man einfach nicht
voneinander trennen
die mehrheitsverhältnisse bleiben aber
verträgt was also tun immerhin der
thüringer generalsekretär wald wird an
der spitze einer cdu-delegation mit den
linken ausloten was geht
der landrat aus dem eichsfeld hat er
ganz klare vorstellungen
man würde uns und unserem land einen
dienst erweisen wenn man vom bund und
von anderen bundesländern uns jetzt mal
in ruhe ließe und die abgeordneten
entscheiden ließen
und ich hätte die hoffnung dass eben
selbige abgeordnete jetzt erst einmal
sagen bitte die alte regierung möge
weitermachen und dann möge es so schnell
wie möglich zu neuwahlen kommen
ob sich dann mindestens vier
oppositionsabgeordnete finden die einen
linken ministerpräsidenten wählen
ab kommender woche könnte es wieder sehr
spannend werden in erfurt
per mausklick bestellt und wenn es nicht
passt oder gefällt ab in die post und
zurück damit so einfach ist einkaufen im
internet
das problem jedes sechste paket in
deutschland geht inzwischen zurück und
viele lieferungen rund 20 millionen pro
jahr landen direkt auf dem müll
denn das ist für die firmen oft billiger
als die wahren umständlich auszupacken
und zu überprüfen
die bundesregierung will dem jetzt einen
riegel vorschieben frank buchwald neue
ware zurückgeschickt bisher landen viele
dieser retouren im müll
das will die bundesregierung ändert sie
nimmt die versandhändler in die pflicht
wir wollen genau wissen welche maßnahmen
sie ergreifen damit unverkaufte produkte
neuwertige produkte eben nicht zu abfall
werden zum beispiel indem sie diese
produkte dort günstiger verkaufen oder
indem sie sich spenden
ein bericht des zdf magazins frontal 21
hatte vor knapp zwei jahren auf diese
wegwerf praxis aufmerksam gemacht eine
sogenannte obhutspflicht soll nun dafür
sorgen dass zurück geschickte ware
sinnvoll verwendet wird und das wird
dazu führen dass wir im bereich
recycling und wiederverwertung
fortschritte machen werden
verbraucherverbände sehen die sache
kritischer es gehe nicht allein um
retouren sondern auch um nachhaltigkeit
in einem sehr viel umfassenderen sinne
über die eu ökodesign verordnung muss
weiter dazu beigetragen werden dass
produkte eben haltbarer werden dass die
reparierbar sind dass man software
updaten kann die betroffene branche
reagiert gelassen verschenken sei
allemal besser als entsorgen das problem
die im steuerrecht wir finden es gut
dass der gesetzentwurf die gesamte
wertschöpfungskette im blick nimmt was
jedoch viel effektiver und nachhaltiger
als sämtliche berichten wäre ist endlich
die sachspenden von der umsatzsteuer zu
befreien
davon jedoch ist bisher nicht die rede
der bundestag soll das neue gesetz im
sommer beschließen
nach wer gehofft hatte der papst würde
heute einen mutigen schritt richtung
erneuerung der katholischen kirche wagen
der wurde enttäuscht keinerlei bewegung
weder beim thema frauen noch beim
zölibat konkret ging es erst mal nur um
die abgelegene amazonas region und die
frage ob franziskus dort verheiratete
männer als priester zulässt um den
extremen priestermangel zu bekämpfen
aus rom andreas postel die erwartung ist
groß auf dem petersplatz in rom als am
mittag das nachsehen und dahle schreiben
des papstes vorgestellt wird carey der
amazon ja geliebtes amazonien so der
titel als reaktion auf die große
amazonas sie nur im oktober franziskus
beklagt den raubbau an der schöpfung
ungerechtigkeit und verbrechen bei der
zerstörung der umwelt und der
vertreibung der indigenen völker und
bietet gleichzeitig ein entgegen entwurf
gang
doch wer erwartet hatte dass sich das
katholische kirchenoberhaupt für eine
priesterweihe für verheiratete diakone
ausspricht wurde enttäuscht auch weil
ämter für frauen liegt der papst
weiterhin ab
natürlich gibt es vor ort immer noch
möglichkeit nur hat das letztendlich
nichts mit der gleichberechtigung zu tun
es wird immer ein punkt geben wo frauen
ausgeschlossen sind und diese tür
scheint jetzt wirklich endgültig
sozusagen enttäuschung mit blick auf den
gerade begonnenen synodalen weg in
deutschland franziskus habe die tür aber
nicht zugemacht sondern geweitet zu
kardinal marx entspricht dem was er
sonst macht prozesse das denkende
anzustoßen und vielleicht auch vor zu
einfachen antworten zu warnen das ist
hier denke ich um ein grundsätzliches
problem geht als nur zu sagen
wie können wir denn am amazonas gebiet
das eine oder andere ändern
das ist in der diskussion auch in der
begleitenden diskussion meiner ansicht
nach deutlich geworden der papst
verweist heute auf das
abschlussdokumente amazonas synode vom
oktober hebt deren bedeutung hervor
damit ist die debatte mit dem heutigen
tag nicht beendet sondern geht weiter
ein kurzer blick in die usa auf die
zweite vorwahl im us präsidentschafts
rennen und die zweite niederlage für joe
biden
der ehemalige vizepräsident landete bei
den demokraten nur auf platz fünf im
us-bundesstaat new hampshire konnte der
linksgerichtete senator bernie sanders
die meisten stimmen sammeln gefolgt vom
früheren bürgermeister peter ditsch und
der senatoren mit logischer das zdf das
schweizer fernsehen und die washington
post hatten die dunklen geschäfte von
bnd und ce gestern ans licht gebracht
jetzt gibt es weltweit aufklärungsbedarf
einen untersuchungsausschuss fordern
politiker in der schweiz
dort hatten die geheimdienste über eine
tarnfirma verschlüsselungstechnik an
mehr als 100 staaten verkauft und ihre
kunden dann fleißig abgehört bis 1993 in
berlin zeigt sich die opposition
alarmiert florian neuer
mittwochnachmittag ein routinetermin
hier tagt das parlamentarische
kontrollgremium kurzfristig heute mit
neuer tagesordnung ganz oben nun die
große abhöraktion rubicon von bmw und ca
gestern enthüllt was über jahrzehnte
hinweg auch europäische
partner bündnispartner befreundete
staaten abgehört worden sind das ist
schon eine dimension die man sich nicht
hätte vorstellen können
jahrzehntelang hatten bmw und sie über
die schweizer crypto ag weltweit
manipulierte verschlüsselungs geräte
verkauft was die opposition besonders
alarmiert eine passage aus dem
geheimdienstunterlagen die jährliche
gewinnausschüttung heißt es dort wurde
dem bnd haushalt zugeschlagen
haushaltsausschuss und rechnungshof
hatten darüber keine kontrolle
aus den akten geht eindeutig hervor dass
es hier schwarze kassen wohl gegeben hat
die frage ist was ist mit den geldern
passiert vertreter der koalition wiegeln
ab der bnd vor langem ausgestiegen das
ganze nur noch historisch interessant ob
es aber für uns heute relevant ist
da das werden wir sehr sorgfältig
untersuchen am grössten heute die
aufregung in der schweiz
parteiübergreifend fragt man sich hier
was wusste der bundesrat also die
schweizer regierung hier geht es um die
neutralität der schweiz es geht um die
glaubwürdigkeit der schweiz deshalb
müssen wir sehen dass man sofort zu
untersuchungsergebnissen kommt möglich
dafür eine parlamentarische
untersuchungskommission die krypto leaks
bekommen ein nachspiel
angriffe gegen amtsträger wie zum
beispiel lokalpolitiker häufen sich aber
auch feuerwehrleute polizisten
mitarbeiter in jobcentern oder lehrer
werden schnell zur zielscheibe
forscher der uni gießen haben
potenzielle opfer nun im auftrag des
beamtenbundes befragt herauskam zum
beispiel mehr als die hälfte der
teilnehmenden beamten im justizvollzug
wurde im letzten jahr betont peter
theißen heike messinger kundenberaterin
im jobcenter in bischofsheim
da hat man es oft mit frustrierten
menschen zu tun zuweilen kommt es auch
zu bedrohlichen situationen als
sogenannte sicherheits partien berät
heike messinger deshalb auch ihre
kollegen dann probiert erstmal ruhig zu
bleiben und dann ist aber wirklich so
der erste gedanke die eigene sicherheit
deswegen haben wir alle kollegen in
allen häusern geschult
immer häufiger kommt es zu gewalt gegen
mitarbeiter im öffentlichen dienst 2014
eine tödliche messerattacke im jobcenter
rotenburg 2016 in gelnhausen wird einem
gerichtsvollzieher in den kopf
geschossen solcher angriffe sind aber
nur die spitze des eisbergs wie eine
hessische studien und erstmals offen
legt von gewalt in einem breiten ausmaß
betroffen sind natürlich polizeibeamte
aber auch lehrerinnen und lehrer
gerichtsvollzieher der justizvollzug und
die mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter der
agentur für arbeit
die studie zeigt auch dass zahlreiche
mitarbeiter im öffentlichen dienst angst
an ihrem arbeitsplatz haben
wir reden viel in unserer gesellschaft
über die würde des menschen häufig bei
straftätern tun wir das aber bei diesen
opfern
da vergessen wir auch die haben eine
menschenwürde und die wird eben häufig
in unseren amtsstuben massiv verletzt
manchmal sind es schon einfache bauliche
maßnahmen wie eine offene tür zum
kollegen die etwas mehr sicherheit am
arbeitsplatz bringen
ein kleiner baustein im
sicherheitskonzept des jobcenters
bischofsheim
sie gaben sich am telefon als polizisten
aus und betrogen vor allem senioren um
mehr als 3 millionen euro jetzt wurden
28 verdächtige bei razzien in nordrhein
westfalen und der türkei festgenommen
und 100 fälle und immer die gleiche
masche die anrufe erzählten den opfern
von einer angeblichen diebesbande in der
umgebung dann schickten sie komplizen
die geld und wertsachen zur vermeintlich
sicheren aufbewahrung abholten und jetzt
noch der abschied von einem der
bekanntesten deutschen regisseure
herbstmilch war sein kinodebüt gleich
hoch gelobt oder auch comedian
harmonists zwei von vielen filmen wie
das können von joseph vilsmaier zeigen
mit 81 ist er nun gestorben
vielen wird auch seine besondere
herzlichkeit und heimatliebe in
erinnerung bleiben brigitte sagen
das konnte so nur er ein dokumentarfilm
als liebeserklärung an die heimat
bavaria der spagat zwischen wohligen
klischees und sensibler wahrhaftigkeit
war joseph vilsmaiers stärke von seinem
bayern noch der nie lange getrennt sein
flughafen voll mitgehen irgendwohin dem
franziskaner oder aequo es weißwürste
und leberkäs und da bin ich wieder zu
hause
angefangen hat er als kameramann als
regisseur ist vilsmaier ein spätzünder
fast 50 jahre alt bei herbst nicht sein
gespür für große geschichten beschert
ihm große kinoerfolge wie die comedian
harmonists international für aufsehen
sorgt die romanverfilmung schlafes
bruder die sogar für einen golden globe
nominiert wird
klug und uhr bayerisch verschoben ist
vilsmaier ebenso wie seine filmfigur der
brandner kaspar
ein mann der den tod überlistet am ende
geht das aber doch bloß im film im alter
von 81 jahren ist josef ismayr nun im
kreise seiner familie gestorben
und jetzt zum fußball nadja mit einem
milliardenspiel dass seine schatten
vorauswirft denn im sommer 2021 wird die
reformierte klub-weltmeisterschaft der
fifa in china alle bisher dagewesenen
dimensionen sprengen ein turnier mit
dann 24 vereinsmannschaften das den
confed-cup der nationalteams ersetzen
wird
im vergangenen herbst hatte das fifa
council die pläne von präsident gianni
infantino durchgewunken
der schweizer spricht von einer
historischen entscheidung dem turnier
sieger winkt ein dreistelliger
ohne nennbetrag markus hahn ist für uns
am sitz der uefa in new york können wir
davon ausgehen dass dann auch ein
deutscher klub mitmischt aus europa
werden 8 mannschaften an der club wm
teilnehmen und so wie ich aus
verbandskreisen höhere wird bayern
münchen dabei sein denn die uefa wird
wohl die champions league sieger der
jahre 18 19 20 und 21 entsenden und
mindestens zwei wenn ich vier vereine
der uefa club rangliste und dann ist
bayern münchen gesetzt bei diesem sagen
wir lottogewinn turnier klub wm der fifa
der weltverband wird dann anfang märz
offiziell die 24 teilnehmenden
mannschaften bekannt geben
experten sagen schon alleine 50
millionen us-dollar antrittsprämie soll
es pro klub geben 115 millionen wird
dann der sieger einstreichen absurd viel
geld das dann auch die bayern verdienen
werden und wer soll sie dann auf
nationalen level noch stoppen die
reichen jedenfalls werden immer reicher
vielen dank für diese informationen
markus haben in antholz in südtirol
beginnen morgen die 52
weltmeisterschaften im biathlon das
deutsche team hofft gleich zu beginn auf
eine medaille bei der mixed staffel
startschuss um 14 45 live im zdf
der körper sei nett positive signale bei
denise herrmann fühlt sich fit der
erwartungsdruck vor dieser mixed-staffel
für die 31 jährige kein problem
natürlich für das team wünschenswert
wenn der positiven einstieg in die wm
losgeht dass man da wirklich so ein floh
bekommt dass man das ganze team auch die
nächsten tage dazwischen kann 2009 10
gab es zum auftakt der wm silber morgen
wird franziska preuß die staffel
anlaufen dann denise herrmann gefolgt
von antifa und benedikt doll soll
vollenden und jürgen klinsmann hat sich
auf facebook nach seinem überraschenden
rücktritt als trainer von hertha bsc
entschuldigt die art und weise sei frack
und kritikwürdig gewesen an den gründen
ändert das aber nichts
tja aber immerhin eine entschuldigung
und wir haben jetzt noch die lottozahlen
die gewinnzahlen lauten 2 10 24 31 1 und
40 49 und die superzahl 3 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf.de und im zdf text auf seite 55 7
das wetter bringt regen und schnee von
westen nur im osten ist das noch länger
sonnig die details hat gleich gunther
tiersch viertel vor zehn begrüßt sie
claus kleber im heute journal
haben sie noch einen schönen abend
bleiben sie uns gewogen und bis morgen
[Musik]
guten abend liebe zuschauer auch in den
küsten legt sich der sturm wieder etwas
haben es kommt schon wieder ein neues
tief bringt uns regen und schnee morgen
hier liegt es den abendstunden bei
irland zieht sehr schnell nach
deutschland erreicht es morgen vormittag
und dann zieht es eben in den
mittelgebirgen mit schnee sonst mit
regen über uns hinweg in den nächsten
tagen wird es dann aus dem südwesten
auch deutlich milder werden ja heute
nacht gibt es kaum noch schauer aber es
wird gefährlich glatt werden denn
teilweise erreichen wir frost mit 0 bis
-5 grad der wind wird nicht mehr so
stürmisch an den küsten in der kommenden
nacht sein und morgen vormittag beginnt
es dann schon wieder neu mit neuem regen
hier im westen im sauerland
mittelgebirge ober von 3 400 meter
schneit ist zum teil eine ganze menge im
osten und süden ist es noch sonnig aber
zum nachmittag hin kommen schnee und
regen auch an die elbe an und im westen
gibt es dann noch einige schauer meist
ist es nur noch regen ist wird ja dort
ein bisschen milder werden und
vorübergehend wird auch stürmisch wieder
in den mittelgebirgen hier im westen und
an den küsten aus süden die temperaturen
dann nur im westen bisschen höher
acht bis zehn grad dort sonst etwa 4 bis
7 grad und die aussichten bringen uns
dann am freitag im südosten noch ein
bisschen regen und schnee dann wird es
wäre sehr mild am wochenende regen im
norden und süden die sonne aber am
sonntag kommt ein neuer sturm an der
küste orkan ihnen noch einen schönen
abend und machen sie's gut